now that there are over 1400 videos i've
realized it's a little hard to navigate
especially for people who are just
starting off or they're just starting to
review their mathematics and they want
to know what playlist should they watch
in which order so the most and i'll
focus on the mathematics but maybe we'll
branch off that into the sciences a
little bit so the most basic mathematics
playlist i have is the arithmetic
playlist
arithmetic
playlist and that covers
literally everything starting with 1
plus 1 equals 2 and it goes through
multiplying adding subtracting dividing
decimals and doing those with multiple
digit numbers if you're already very
familiar with that you can skip the
arithmetic playlist after that
there is the pre-algebra
the pre-algebra playlist
pre-algebra and as the name implies it
kind of covers the basic things you need
to know before you really embark on
algebra like
adding and subtracting and multiplying
and dividing negative numbers adding and
subtracting multiplying and dividing
fractions
units things like exponents all the
things that you need before you really
start to understand algebra and if you
know that that's great but i find for a
lot of people haven't been to school in
a long time this is usually a good place
to start although even in arithmetic
some of the decimal review won't hurt
now once you have pre-algebra out of the
way either you watch that playlist and i
you know as i say it never hurts to
re-review it you might actually learn
some things that you had never picked up
when you had first learned it when you
were in school
then you're ready for the algebra
playlist and here it gets a little
confusing because obviously there's so
much need for algebra that i've done a
lot of algebra content but because
there's so much algebra content on the
site i have several playlists that have
the word algebra and it can get a little
confusing so a good kind of the core
algebra playlist is the one that just is
called algebra and it starts literally
at the most simple algebra problems and
it works all the way through algebra two
types of problems so this is your
traditional algebra one and algebra 2
curriculums so this is one
and two so the playlist that just says
algebra that's kind of the core when i
just started off i started with very
basic algebra and i kept working now
there's a couple of other playlists that
i've done since then that are also
algebra and they have the word algebra
in it and they're kind of related to
this i would watch this one first
because it goes in a nice progression
but related to this if you want to see a
lot of worked examples you could watch
the
you could watch the algebra one playlist
algebra one playlist that i've done a
lot more recently and actually all of
these videos aren't hd and these are
actually a hundred and something
problems and or actually videos where i
do worked examples and i go do it out of
the ck12.org
algebra one open source textbook so it
very cl it really covers every concept
that's in the california state standards
and so this is really great for review
so if you're already if you're already
pretty familiar with algebra and you
just want to make sure that you get some
practice watch this playlist maybe even
pause it after you see the problem try
to do the problem yourself
if you've watched this one this will
only be more practice for you and like
you know along these lines i have a
couple of other a couple of other
playlists that are just kind of more
work examples for algebra i have the
california standards test
california
standards
california standards test algebra
algebra 1 and once again this is
literally example problems from the
california standards algebra 1 exam so
this is regardless of where you live
this is really good review for algebra
and then there's another california
standards i'll just call it california
standards
standards algebra 2
algebra 2. so all of these playlists
these kind of branch off of that core
algebra playlist and they're all a lot
of work examples so if you feel like you
know your algebra pretty well already
and you just want to see a lot of
examples these are a good place to turn
to
now after you get just the basic algebra
out of the way the next playlist i would
start tackling i would look at the
geometry playlist
you could look at the geometry playlist
and you could even start to look at the
geometry playlist once you start to go
maybe halfway through the algebra
playlist once you have the kind of the
basics of algebra out of the way you can
start with the the geometry playlist and
then after geometry you can go into
trigonometry
trigonometry
and then also after you know after after
the algebra playlist you really are
ready for the pre-calculus playlist let
me write that down you are ready for the
pre-calculus playlist but i would i
would at least familiarize yourself with
the geometry and the trigonometry so let
me write precalculus here
pre-calculus
pre-calculus here
i think in most schools you take
arithmetic then pre-algebra then you
take algebra one then geometry then
algebra two which has a lot of review of
algebra one and then you take
trigonometry and pre-calculus
usually your junior year your senior
year is kind of the this is kind of the
precalculus curriculum
and then you take calculus so after you
do all of this then you're ready for the
calculus playlist
then you're ready for the calculus
playlist let me do this in a new color
i'm running out let me do it in
other than that then you're ready for
the calculus playlist and this is a
pretty extensive playlist i think i'm
pushing almost 200 videos here and this
really is the first three semesters so
you can kind of use calculus one two
and three and i might actually have
thought about breaking this up into
multiple playlists it does all of
differential calculus integral calculus
multivariable calculus vector calculus
so this calculus playlist is quite quite
extensive so i might just i might break
it up
but while once you're pretty far into
the calculus playlist you actually don't
have to
complete it once you start me seeing me
do things like partial derivatives and
divergence and curl and and all the
vector calculus stuff you could actually
also branch off you could also branch
off into several other of the kind of
advanced topic videos you could branch
off into differential equations
differential
equations which is usually a
sophomore level class in college and
also linear algebra
linear algebra
and this is an important one to point
out because something says hey linear
algebra that sounds simpler than
non-linear algebra maybe that's a basic
algebra course no this is quite advanced
a mathematically
a mathematically
rigorous
type of kind of a mathy subject but once
you're reasonably
far through calculus you could even if
you have a strong you could you might
even be able to start the linear algebra
after just doing a little bit of the
pre-calculus of the algebra but it's a
little bit mathematically sophisticated
so you might want to hold off on that
now on top of that if you look at kind
of the sciences that we have on the khan
academy we also have physics and you can
really start the physics playlist as it
is after you have a good proficiency on
the algebra playlist so after you've
watched the algebra playlist you can
start watching physics
you can watch the physics playlist
and the chemistry playlist you don't
need a lot of algebra it has a little
bit of algebra in it you could just
watch the first part of the algebra
playlist if you need to
but it's a good it's a good thing to get
out of the way so you can also that's a
good branching point for
just the chemistry playlist
for the chemistry and then the biology
playlist doesn't have a lot of math in
it the only math that is there is a
little bit of
statistics and probability in the
genetics so i'd also at least at least
get pre-algebra out of the way but
probably the algebra algebra's core to
pretty much everything
biology and then the other math that we
have on the side of statistics and there
too i i go at a slightly more advanced
level than what you would normally see
kind of a very basic statistics course
so there too i would i would see this
algebra as the branching point so there
are two
algebra so the algebra the one that just
has the word algebra is kind of the core
playlist the core for pretty much
everything else and the playlists that
say algebra one california standards
test algebra one algebra two these are
just worked examples and then linear
algebra is actually a quite advanced
course so if we look at the site itself
let me bring
the site here
if we look at the site itself
we just to make sure you understand all
of the different playlists here so these
are sat problems i've worked through all
the problems in this book i understand
there's a new addition now so i'll have
to do some more problems these are
worked gmat examples this is the
chemistry playlist that i told you about
that you should probably watch the well
you don't have to watch the entire
algebra playlist but it's good to have a
decent working understanding of algebra
biology linear algebra this is the
advanced playlist that i talked about
this is probably after at least you've
watched the pre-calculus playlist but
even some calculus wouldn't hurt this is
the algebra one this is worked examples
from the ck12.org
ck12.org open source textbook it's good
for if you want to just get a lot of
algebra 1 examples this is the core
algebra playlist right here it starts at
very basic linear equations
and then it goes quite advanced into
kind of kind of a lot of algebra two
types concepts these are more examples
california standards and all of that and
then i will go all of the playlists i
think that gave a pretty good overview
the last piece i have some of these
finance videos and these are kind of
they jump around some of them you
probably just need about pre-algebra
level of understanding some of them you
might want to have at least algebra
under your belt some of them even
venture a little bit into what i would
consider precalculus so these are a
little bit more hodgepodge and i might
try to structure them a little bit but
most of them do not require too much
math especially things like venture
capital and capital markets the
fractional the banking playlist these
require these require very very little
very little mathematics and i think that
that pretty much covers everything oh i
also have this place on california
standards test geometry so if we go back
to this we have our core geometry
playlist and for examples we have the
california
california standards
california standards
geometry playlist so these are worked
examples
as well